Transcriber: Aya Gamal
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
دي سماح، ودي أختها التؤام عبير،
مامتهم قالت لهم النهاردة الغدا قلقاس.
سماح راحت دبدبت واتشعننت،
وقالتلها لاء مش هاكل قلقاس أنا.
عبير قامت داخله عليها وجيباها من
قفاها، وقالتلها بس سيبني أنا أتكلم.
وقامت داخله على مامتها وقايللها هتقعدي
تتعبي نفسك ليه يا ماما، وتقشري وتعملي،
ما في كيس بسلة في الفريزر؛
بقاله أسبوعين مستني اللي يحن عليه ويعمله.
ما تعمليه وتخلصي بدل التعب دة،
وفعلًا أقنعت مامتها أنها تعمل كيس البسلة
بدل القلقاس.
نقدر نقول أن عبير عاقلة
على عكس سماح، أو فى الحقيقة
هى عندها “ذكاء عاطفي“.
ممكن تكونوا بتسألوا نفسكوا هو ايه
هو “الذكاء العاطفي” دة.
طب هو عندنا كلنا!
“الذكاء العاطفي” هو أنك تقدر تفهم
نفسك ومشاعرك ومشاعر اللي حواليك.
عشان يبقى عندك “الذكاء العاطفي”،
هتشتغل على أربع حاجات بس؛
الوعي الذاتي، التحكم بالذات، تحفيز الذات،
والتعاطف والمهارات الإجتماعية.
أول حاجة هي الوعي الذاتي، في يوم
عبير كانت قاعدة بتلعب على البلايستيشن.
وسماح قاعدة بتزن على مامتها
عشان تلعب معاها
قامت مامتها داخله على عبير،
وقايللها: عبير، لاعبي أختك معاكي.
عبير قامت أدت دراع البلايستيشن لسماح،
سماح ماسكة الدراع
تشوط عشان نمشي اللاعب يمين، يمشي
شمال، تشوط الكرة، الكُرة مش بتتشاط،
وإذ فجأةً طلع دراع البلايستيشن مش متوصل.
قامت دابة خناقة قد كدة مع عبير
وقايللها: على فكرة أنتي واحدة أنانية.
عبير قعدت تفكر مع نفسها،
هو أنا فعلًا أنانية
طب إزاي، أنا واحدة معطأة جدًا،
وقعدت تحاول تفهم شخصيتها؛
ودة اللي بنسميه “الوعي الذاتي“.
“الوعي الذاتي” هو أننا نقدر نفهم مشاعرنا،
ومشاعر اللي حوالينا.
ثاني حاجة، لو بصيتوا فالشنطة
اللي أخدوتها وأنتم داخلين، هتلاقوا ورقتين،
دي أول ورقة، هتختاروا من الورقة دي
خمس صفات؛
الصفات دى لازم تكون
أنتوا شايفين أنها فيكم بجد.
بعد كدة، عالمين النفس: “جوزيف لوفت”
و”هارينغتون انغهام” عملوا الورقة التانية،
اللي هو نموذج” شباك جوهاري”،
في أول خانة اللي هي المنطقة المفتوحة،
هتكتبوا فيها حاجات الناس عرفاها
عنكوا وأنتوا عارفينها عن نفسكوا.
ودول الخمس حاجات اللي أنتوا
أخترتوهم في الأول.
يعني أنا مثلًا أخترت جميلة، وذكية،
ودمي خفيف، وقمورة، وقمر.
تاني خانة، وهي المنطقة العمياء؛
دي هتكتبوا فيها حاجات الناس شايفاها
عنكوا، بس أنتوا مش مقتنعين بيها.
ممكن الناس تقولك: أنت عصبي جدًا،
بس أنت مش مقتنع.
ثالث خانة، هي المنطقة المخفية؛
دي هتكتب فيها حاجات أنت
عارفها عن نفسك، بس محدش عارفها عنك.
ممكن تكون أنت واحد بتحب الرسم،
بس مش قايل لحد أنك
بتحب الرسم أو محدش يعرف.
آخر خانة، هي المنطقة المجهولة؛ دي
هتسيبوها فاضية لحد ما تعدي فترة من الوقت،
وتبتدوا تكتشفوا فى نفسكوا صفات،
وتقوموا كاتبنها فيها.
بعد كدة، هتقعدوا مع أشخاص، عيلتكوا،
أصحابكم، وقرايبكم،
وتدوهم جدول الصفات
اللي أتكلمنا عليه في الأول،
وتقوللهم أختاروا صفات من الجدول دة
أن هي فيكم، واقنعوني بيها.
كل ما حد يقنعك بصفة،
هتكتبها في المنطقة المفتوحة.
كل ما نقعد مع ناس أكتر،
كل ما الوعي الذاتي هيزيد أكتر.
تاني حاجة في الذكاء العاطفي
هو التحكم بالذات.
“التحكم بالذات” هو
تغيير الأفكار السلبية التلقائية.
لو جربتوا أن أنتوا تقفوا، وتثبتوا رجليكم،
وتلفوا علي قد ما تقدروا، بعد كدة رجعتوا،
غمضتوا عنيكوا، وتخيلتوا
أن أنتوا جسمكوا مرن جدًا،
وأن هو عبارة عن صلصال أو
مفيهوش عضم أصلًا، بعد كدة فتحتوا عنيكوا،
ولفيتوا نفس اللفة تاني؛
هتلاقوا نفسكوا عديتوا أكتر
ودي اللي بتأيد تجربة
“البرت اليس” و“أرون بيك“؛
أنه عشان تغير أي إنسان، محتاج تغير تفكيره،
وأن تغيير التفكير، يؤدي إلى تغيير السلوك،
اللي بيؤدي إلى تغيير الشعور.
في مرة كانوا سماح وعبير بيتسابقوا مين
اللي هيقعد في العربية في الكرسي اللي قدام.
عبير عشان عندها ذكاء عاطفي، غمضت عنيها،
وتخليت قد ايه هتستمتع بالقعدة ورا لوحدها
في الكنبة، وفعلًا استمتعت أكتر.
ثالث حاجة في الذكاء العاطفي؛
هو تحفيز الذات، هنحفز نفسنا بثلاث حاجات:
أول حاجة؛ بناء فريق دعم، تاني حاجة؛
تحفيز هرمونات السعادة في الجسم،
وآخر حاجة؛ تأجيل الاستمتاع.
عشان نبني فريق دعم؛ محتاجين
نحاوط نفسنا ببيئة فيها راحة وثقة،
نبني علاقات إيجابية مع الناس،
لازم أقعد أفكر نفسي كل شوية بأهمية
عيلتي، وأصحابي، وشغلي.
لازم تحط لنفسك أهداف صغيرة،
عشان كل ما تحققها؛
جسمك يبتدي يفرز هرمونات السعادة
زي “الدوبامين“.
في تجربة اتعملت، جابوا أطفال،
قالولهم تاخدوا واحدة مارشيملو دلوقتى،
ولا اتنين كمان ربع ساعة، الأطفال اللي
اختارت أنهم ياخدوا اتنين كمان ربع ساعة،
قاعدوا يشغلوا نفسهم بأنهم
يدندنوا، يغمضوا عنيهم.
بعد سبع دقايق تقريبًا من الوقت،
اكتشفوا أن الأطفال دي رغبتها
فأنها تاخد المارشيملو قلت؛
عشان خلاص بقوا متأكدين
أنهم شوية صغيرين وهيخدوهم.
طيب إزاي ممكن نبقى زيهم.
هحط لنفسي هدف بعيد، واشتغلوا كويس جدًا،
من غير ما اتشتت بالحاجات الصغيرة
اللي بحققها.
آخر حاجة في الذكاء العاطفي؛
هو التعاطف والمهارات الإجتماعية.
الجزء دة هنلخصه في كلمة “value”؛
“V- validate” أنك تفهم شعور اللي قدامك.
“A-ask” أنك تسأله ايه اللي حصل.
“L-listen” أنك تسمعه كويس،
“U-understand” أنك تتأكد من فهمك للموضوع.
“E- emphasis” أنك تحاول تحلله المشكلة.
في يوم سماح كانت سايبة الشكولاتة بتاعتها
في التلاجة، عبير صحيت بليل جاعانة وكلتها.
سماح صحيت تاني يوم ملقتش الشكولاتة
في التلاجة؛ قامت دابة حتة خناقة مع عبير.
وقعدت تكَبر في المشكلة جدًا، عبير
حاولت تلم المشكلة على قد ما تقدر.
وعشان تحللها المشكلة؛
نزلت وجَبتلها واحدة تانية.
مش بقولكوا أن الحاجات دي كلها
هتحصل في يوم وليلة،
بس بعد فترة من تنفيذ الخطوات دي في
حياتنا؛ هتبقى عادة عندنا، فلما نلاقي
دراع البلايستشن مش متوصل،
أو الشكولاتة بتاعتنا متاخدة من التلاجة،
مش هنبقى بنرد الرد السلبي التلقائي؛
من الآخر، هنبقى زي عبير.
(تصفيق)